I just want us to all be aware of this
really cool Google Assistant feature
because it's kind of sick so for years
now if you've ever heard a song in the
background or on the radio or on a mall
or something you just Shazam it it uses
the mic you can figure out what song it
is now if you've been watching Tech
videos you've probably already knew that
Google pixels have had this feature
called now playing where they're
ambiently listening in the background
and keeping a rolling list of all the
songs at play but did you know that you
can actually sing a song yourself and
Google can still try to identify that
song or even if you don't know the words
you can kind of like sing or hum or
whistle the lyrics check this out what
song is this
[Music]
mm-hmm it gives me blue da ba dee 11
match now it's funny it works the exact
same way on the iPhone but it actually
looks kind of cooler in the Google app
for some reason so you hit the mic what
song is this
Eleanor Rigby 47 match that would be
correct I had no idea Google would do
this but now I'm glad I know